We're gettin' through this.
Says the gambler.
I think it's really important
that we create a kind of library
where people can understand
what it took to keep our country free.
Crew: And action!
There is an era
that has to be recreated here.
And there is no way
to have this level of authenticity
without all of our great artists.
Shout out to Colleen.
Four-time Oscar winner.
Stop playing with her.
Austin Butler: Colleen Atwood
is the legend of legends.
I feel so fortunate that we had her.
Anthony Boyle: Colleen's incredible.
She really brings the characters
to the costumes.
I started way before we started shooting,
manufacturing the leathers
the pilots wore,
because no place in the world had them.
Colleen Atwood: And I needed,
for each character,
three or four versions of their costume.
The target for today is Berlin.
We did find a few B-17s in the world
that do occasionally fly.
Gary Goetzman: But they weren't gonna
get us through production,
so we built two B-17s.
All right, boys, huddle up!
We ended up building full exteriors,
and then all the interior pieces.
Chris Seagers: That was,
pretty much, a year's work.
This looks great.
Every authentic detail in here.
The combination of the construction
of the plane, with content walls,
gave the boys the real feeling
of fighters going by and shooting at them.
And I think it helped their reactions,
and them really feeling
what the terror might be like.
Egan: Open fire!
Let 'em have it!
The volume is a gift.
It's phenomenal.
The gimbal's moving,
and you're looking at that plane.
It zooms past.
You know, you're in the plane.
You're fighting.
This project,
it's an absolute dream come true.
Austin Butler: And you end up getting
in this flow where it becomes your life.
You just feel so blessed
to be a part of it.
♪